soir joachim pueyo merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur arte france a en
besoin d'entendre la préfète de l'ordre
qui a demandé des renforts spécialisés
après ces violences urbaines tout
d'abord où on est l'anc est à cette
heure ci est ce que vous avez des
éléments nouveaux apportés alors pour se
détendre l'anc est super niveau du dépôt
cornalin public des autorités
judiciaires donc j'ai pas d'informations
précises mais il semble bien que les
conséquences de la garde à vue et de
l'interpellation d'un jeune qui avait
des produits toxiques sur lui de la
drogue en particulier
et l'origine de ces violences urbaines
qu'on a pu constater dans la nuit de
mardi à mercredi c'est un schéma
malheureusement classique c'est à dire
que vous avez des individus qui vivent
de l'argent facile qui font du trafic
avec des complices et qui ne veulent pas
absolument répondre aux dispositions
réglementaires donc lorsqu'il 10 ans
lorsqu'ils sont interpellés et bien pour
eux ce n'est pas normal et donc ils
réagissent ainsi et on l'a vu c'était
pour attirer la police dans un
guet-apens ce sont des groupes très
mobiles ils ont volé des voitures
les forces de police ont eu des
difficultés à intervenir les
sapeurs-pompiers ont été caillassés
également donc là on est vraiment dans
une situation
et je peux dire que simplement que
l'état de droit doit s'appliquer donc il
faudra continuer bien évidemment à ce
que les lois républicaines soient mises
en oeuvre dans tous les quartiers et
dans tous les territoires ce qui me fait
on s'éteint une ville plutôt le disait
traditionnellement calme est ce que ces
épisodes sont inédits est ce que c'est
la première fois que vous vous les vivez
non ce n'est pas la première fois que
nous y vivons on la lui malheureusement
dans le passé des épisodes de également
similaire avec moins d'importance mais
c'est toujours lié à des interpellations
scellier souvent aaa à des trafics de
drogue également aimé le trafic s'est
amplifiée à mon avis depuis quelques
quelques années et donc je crois qu'il
est grand temps pour rouler pour eux
interview dire que les pouvoirs publics
doit s'atteler parce que on voit que
hong en grain les quartiers on voit que
nous avons un petit groupe d'individus
qui prennent en otage un quartier dans
ce quartier on l'a eu beaucoup de jeunes
qui ont témoigné qu'ils sont pas
d'accord bien évidemment qui s'est passé
nous sommes intervenus d'une manière
très forte dans les équipements
culturels dans les équipements sociaux
dans les équipements sportifs également
donc c'est ce quartier qui a été refait
dans le cadre de la rénovation urbaine
dont beaucoup d'investissement et quand
je vois ce constat évidemment on
s'interroge beaucoup sur la le respect
des lois sur l'état de droit et où là
des véhicules qui ont été incendiés
c'est j'ai une pensée pour les victimes
car ce sont des hommes et des femmes de
familles modestes utilisant véhicule
pour aller travailler ou la vue des
véhicules est utilisée a également qui
sert à des artisans les entreprises qui
ont été incendiés non ce sont des faits
qui sont pas acceptables alors bien
évidemment on a demandé
des forces de police soient renforcés
pendant quelques jours mais je crois
qu'il ya un problème de fond qu'il
faudra poser bien évidemment quand on
observe qu'il ya des mineurs qui à deux
heures du matin une heure du matin un
incendie des véhicules il ya également
des questions à se poser sur la
responsabilité également des familles
bien évidemment ça me paraît nécessaire
de de travailler sur sur le son de
ces problèmes est moins prononcée en
vous vous auriez vous seriez tenté
d'aller demander des comptes aux parents
justement de certains est simplement de
deux de ces mineurs peut-être je pense
que la justice se fera ça me paraît
nécessaire quand vous voyez des
comportements et des incendies qui sont
prévues dans le code sont des peines
fortin qui peuvent être appliqués l110
et plusieurs années de prison dans le
code pénal je pense que c'est nécessaire
de de rendre responsable également ou de
poser la responsabilité d'aider des
parents lorsqu'il s'agit des mineurs
adultes y est c'est autre chose
responsabilité mais également on voit
très bien que l'argent facile et bien on
voit les conséquences ou là des jeunes
parallèlement qui font des efforts pour
des études pour des formations pour un
cursus de travail et là je trouve que
c'est très positif et puis vous avez une
petite minorité quelques individus qui
ne veulent pas entrer dans ce dispositif
qui ne veulent pas respecter des valeurs
républicaines parce que quand vous avez
d'insécurité ben vous mettez en cause
les libertés individuelles et
collectives également des habitants on
voit malheureusement cette minorité se
multiplient dans plusieurs villes de
france il ya eu des incidents quasi
similaire il ya deux jours à lyon
d'ailleurs le votre homologue vers
l'europe écologie sévère grigori nous
tous et nous disait qu'en gros il y
avait assez de vidéos caméras
surveillance qu'il allait faire même un
audit pour connaître évidemment leur
utilité vous n'êtes pas du tout dans le
même discours par rapport aux caméras
aujourd'hui vous en demandez peut-être
plus encore parce que j'ai installé sur
la ville qu'une ville moyenne plus de 60
caméras vidéo protection et donc nous
allons encore renforcer le dispositif
parce que les caméras permettent
effectivement de capter des images
[Musique]
voilà rond
on arrive en tout cas la fin de cette
interview et on va on a compris donc
vous allez renforcer encore ce
dispositif de vidéo caméra surveillance
en tout cas le rn lui de son côté 1 pour
une autre élection a appelé à rétablir
l'ordre et la sécurité dans les
quartiers où vous êtes sur cette ligne
on n'attendait pas forcément un
socialiste
sur ce thème vous vous rejoignez en tout
cas dans cette demande aujourd'hui de de
fermeté contre une minorité et moi je
suis un élu républicain
discours que j'ai aujourd'hui je l' ai
toujours eues c'est pas nouveau parce
que malheureusement j'ai été confronté
également à des événements il ya
quelques années par par des violences
urbaines donc la question de fond qu'on
doit se poser c'est l'application de nos
lois républicaines elles doivent
s'appliquer partout sur tous les
territoires et c'est pas mon avis une
question de gauche ou de droite moi je
pense que on devrait avoir un consensus
sur cette sécurité qui est indispensable
pour nos libertés voilà ce que ce que je
peux dire alors si des hommes politiques
de droite et de gauche se rejoignent sur
ce sujet là c'est une bonne chose ça
veut dire qu'il faudra renforcer encore
les dispositifs renforcer les moyens de
la policière lui des efforts de fées
faut le reconnaître a continué renforcer
les moyens de la justice j'ai écouté le
garde des sceaux récemment il a indiqué
que dans le budget 2022 aurait
effectivement des des renforts c'est une
bonne chose donc il faut travailler
parce qu'on voit très bien que les
conséquences sont graves çà çà çà
d'élite notre société ça met en cause
les valeurs républicaines pour lequel
nous sommes particulièrement attachés là
ça veut dire de la rigueur ça veut dire
de la détermination ça veut dire
également de la fermeté y compris dans
les sanctions
merci beaucoup le quément philo d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur france 5 mai
aps d'alençon